okay so we've been talking more and more
about Donald Trump's impeachment and
calls for impeachment and I want to step
back from that for a moment and just
talk about sort of some historical
parallels between Richard Nixon in 1974
and Donald Trump in 2019 and the top
level parallels are pretty obvious right
at the top level we have a attempt to
obstruct investigations into their
respective presidencies cover-up
attempts and this is the kind of
broadest way in which Nixon 74 and Trump
20 19 or similar but as Kelby Adams
points out in a really good multi post
thread on Twitter articles of
impeachment against Nixon were filed in
part for using his power as president
directly and through subordinates to
impede obstruct an investigation into
the Watergate Hotel break-in the second
part of the Nixon impeachment articles
was for violating the constitutional
rights of citizens or contravening the
laws governing agencies of the executive
branch when you look at the Moller
report it literally spells out examples
of Trump doing the same thing all over
the place if you look at pages 77 and
113 of the first volume of the report if
you look at pages 177 and 178 of Part
two pay special attention to footnote 10
91 about impeachment not substituting
criminal liability in the Moller report
which maybe we'll talk about tomorrow we
learn that Donald Trump prevented aides
from testifying before Congress another
example of obstruction and there are a
whole bunch of other examples we could
go through which already gives us
parallels for two out of three of the
impeachment articles filed against
Richard Nixon that we can find in the
Trump administration then we get to the
third part of Nixon's articles of
impeachment quote failing without lawful
cause or excuse to produce papers and
things as directed by duly authorized
subpoenas issued by the Committee on the
Judiciary of the House of
Representatives this is part three of
Nixon
impeachment articles and it exploded
over the weekend for Donald Trump we
found out that Trump has been directing
his entire administration to simply not
provide documents not respond to
subpoenas not show up and testify when
it comes to some individuals in the
Justice Department and this is above and
beyond the tax returns okay which aren't
even really a part of this Donald Trump
and everyone around him have tried to
use their power to obstruct the full
investigation into a whole bunch of
different stuff including the Trump
Tower meeting including financial crimes
on and on and on so there are a lot of
similarities if you look at the articles
of impeachment of Richard Nixon but then
let's go even further Trump and Nixon
both hated and regularly attacked the
media Trump's framing is if not for the
press unfairly targeting me none of this
impeachment talk would even been going
on nothing would even have been going on
none of the Moller probe or a lot of the
Moller probe would never have gotten
going if it weren't for the evil press
Nixon had almost the same position Nixon
thought that the media made him lose to
John F Kennedy in 1960 he would
regularly ramble against the media etc
etc and very very similar attacks when
you look at presidential power Nixon at
his core didn't care about the limits of
presidential power Trump similarly dozen
obstructing investigations installing
puppet cabinet members firing people and
trying to fire even more people one of
those that he failed to get fired was
Robert Muller himself
when Don McGann said I'm not going to do
it both Nixon and Trump lost top-level
staff to scandals and criminality that
was part of the bigger picture of what
was going on in the Nixon administration
and there's a long list of people that
both Trump and Nixon lost I won't name
them all former elected Republican
officials some Republicans are now
running for office who are saying it's
time for Trump to go but ultimately what
saves Trump is a key difference between
1974 and 2019
in 2070 for eventually it became known
to Nixon that elected Republicans were
turning on him elected Republicans
recognized they are not going to be able
to continue their support for President
Nixon and it is going to have to be a
yes vote on conviction on impeachment
and that is ultimately what caused
Richard Nixon to resign I don't know
that you're going to see that with
Donald Trump in 2019 because Republicans
in 1974 were willing to go beyond
partisanship and they realized Nixon
horribly damaged the country and he
needs to be removed so far we have not
seen that same point of view from any
prominent current elected Republicans
we've seen it from some former
Republicans we've seen it from george w
bush's former speechwriter we see it
from william weld who's running a
primary campaign against donald trump
but you need two-thirds of the senate to
convict on impeachment democrats can't
do it now democrats can't even do it if
they do well in 2020 in the senate
because you need a two-thirds majority
which democrats are not going to have
after the 2020 election
so unless 2019 becomes like 1974 and
that republicans realize this is this is
just bad for the country we have to
cross party lines here you are not going
to see impeachment of the President of
the United States
one other note on this impeachment of
Nixon actually failed before it
succeeded in getting him to resign
before the Watergate break-in in 72 some
Democrats already believed that it was
time to impeach Nixon you had House
resolutions 975 976 and 989 they were
all submitted to the House Judiciary
and they went nowhere in 72 in 73 there
was an attempt to impeach Nixon for
something unrelated to the Watergate
break-in for Nixon's secret bombing of
Cambodia articles of impeachment were
introduced by congressman Robert Dryden
at the time and that didn't go anywhere
so understand that these are very long
processes and at this point in time
aside from my opinion as to whether
Trump should be impeached I genuinely
would not be a
to say whether the evidence suggests
impeachment is or is not likely because
if history tells us anything these
things can be extraordinarily
unpredictable and have a very very long
time period during which they develop we
will see the similarities between Nixon
74 and Trump 2019 growing by the day if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video